Постійні обстріли, поранені і вбиті українські вояки.
Майже щодня повідомляється про порушення
бойовиками на Донбасі режиму припинення вогню.
Мінські домовленості фактично не виконуються.
Чи можна їх реанімувати чи замінити більш дієвими?
Мінські угоди, так званий "Мінськ-1", підписали
у вересні 2014-го, щоб припинити бойові дії на Донбасі.
Домовленості не спрацювали і рівно 5 років тому
в столиці Білорусі лідери України, Німеччини, Франції
та Росії узгодили вже так званий "Мінськ-2" з метою
виконання мінських угод та деескалації конфлікту.
Утім, домовленості все одно не працюють
і трактуються сторонами по-різному.
За словами опитаних DW експертів, у команді
президента Зеленського схиляються до нового
документа - до своєрідного "Мінська-3", який був би
удосконаленням "Мінська-2", але враховував
нинішні реалії та українські інтереси, адже "Мінськ-2"
робився поспіхом, щоб припинити гарячу фазу
бойових дій, а не на перспективу. Втім, Росії,
як і раніше, нові домовленості не потрібні.
"Мінськ-2" цілком влаштовує Кремль для тиску
на Україну, Захід та переговорний процес.
Путін не йде на поступки і не хоче навіть
коми змінювати в мінських угодах, тож сценарій
нової угоди поки видається маловірогідним.
Укладення нових домовленостей із залученням
Сполучених Штатів і Великобританії
до мирного процесу нині теж не обговорюється.
Трамп був заклопотаний справою про імпічмент
через телефонну розмову з Зеленським.
Окрім того, президентська кампанія у США
набирає обертів. Вашингтон не прагне активної
участі у переговорах щодо Донбасу і рівень
залучення американців до цього процесу навіть знизився.
До того ж, ще не призначений новий
спецпредставник США по Україні замість Курта Волкера.
Лондону зараз теж не до України через проблеми
з виходом Великобританії з ЄС. Таким чином шансів
для розширення формату ще менше, ніж
для суттєвого оновлення тексту мінських угод.
За словами експертів, Росія буде використовувати
переговорний процес про зміни мінських угод,
щоб висувати не нові компромісні пропозиції,
а саме вимоги до України, щоб нинішній варіант
мінських угод здавався Києву меншим злом.
Найбільш вірогідний варіант, до якого схиляються
оглядачі, - це своєрідний "Мінськ-2 +", тобто не нова
домовленість, а трансформація нинішніх мінських угод
за рахунок їхньої конкретизації, зокрема щодо
відведення сил і засобів. А також узгодження
окремих пунктів між собою. Передусім щодо
проведення виборів в ОРДЛО та контролю над кордоном.
Київ наполягає, що спершу безпека,
тобто роззброєння бойовиків і виведення
російських військ, встановлення режиму повної тиші
й контролю України над своїм кордоном і лише
після цього проведення виборів.
На останніх переговорах "нормандської четвірки"
в Парижі у грудні 2019 року канцлерка Німеччини
Анґела Меркель заявила, що мінські домовленості
не викарбувані на камені, й підтримала пропозиції
Зеленського щодо змін. Офіційний Париж також
заявляє, що мінські угоди потребують уточнення
та деталізації, особливо щодо послідовності дій,
але знову все впирається в позицію Кремля.
Путін наполягає, що гнучкість мінських угод
не має зачіпати питання передачі контролю над кордоном.
Оглядачі зазначають, що Зеленський не хоче
ще 5 років безуспішних переговорів і поставив
для себе певний дедлайн: якщо до кінця цього року
не вдасться домовитися, то буде план Б.
Що саме, точно поки невідомо. Розглядаються
різні варіанти, передусім ідея миротворчої місії на Донбасі.
Раніше вже йшлося про миротворців
на лінії розмежування, хоча Україна наполягає
на лінії кордону з Росією. Втім, на думку деяких
експертів, миротворці на лінії розмежування
могли б бути першим кроком, якщо потім
гарантуватиметься створення міжнародної
перехідної адміністрації та відновлення Україною контролю над кордоном.